[Musique]
oui
le président coty a consacré cinq jours
à l'alsace l'un des moments les plus
spectaculaires de son voyage aura été la
visite du port de strasbourg salué au
long des quais par des milliers
d'alsaciens et sur le fleuve par le
défilé de la brigade du rhin
au cours de cette visite devait être
inaugurée sur le grand canal d'alsace la
centrale de fessenheim troisième grand
ouvrage prévue par l'électricité de
france pour améliorer la navigation
entre bâle et strasbourg
l'église de fait c'est même déjà
construites possède deux sas et les très
rapides
le passage petit être donné en 11
minutes dans le petit sas en 18 minutes
dans le camp
[Musique]
m
pour l'instant après fait c'est même les
bateaux regagne vers la droite les eaux
du rhin mais dans l'avenir il n'en sera
pas ainsi
dérivé du barrage de kembs le grand
canal s'étendra au delà des centrales de
kembs haute marche m fait ce même
jusqu'à vous gré
[Musique]
électricité de france ap la construction
de la quatrième centrale écluses de
voghel grün 30 au fait ce n'est mais vos
gueules green sur la rive du rhin des
moyens extraordinaires sont utilisés
pour creuser le dernier tronçon du canal
qui termine et totalisera 52 kg
le grand canal a une largeur en surface
de 135 mètres quand le canal de suez
dans la queue sans et panama 91
[Musique]
le fond du canal est entièrement cimenté
les travaux d'aménagement du rhin canal
qui commence au grand barrage de kembs
centrales hydrauliques multiples il y en
aura huit jusqu'à strasbourg
d'autres ont la rive française d'un
remarquable complexe industriel en 1967
la navigation rhénane en aura largement
bénéficié
[Musique]
un supplément d'énergie considérable il
sera gagné on l'évalué à 6 milliards 500
millions de kilowattheures soit le
huitième de la production actuelle
d'électricité en france
[Musique]